Meine Botschaft ist, dass wir Sie beobachten werden
[Applaus]
Das ist alles falsch Ich sollte nicht hier oben sein
Ich sollte wieder in der Schule auf der anderen
Seite des Ozeans sein, aber Sie alle kommen zu uns
jungen Leuten, um Hoffnung zu bekommen, wie können Sie es wagen?  mit deinen leeren worten hast du
mir in meiner kindheit meine träume gestohlen
doch ich bin einer der
glücklichen menschen leiden
menschen sterben
ganze ökosysteme brechen zusammen wir
stehen am anfang eines massensterbens
und alles worüber du reden kannst ist geld und
märchen  des ewigen Wirtschaftswachstums,
wie können Sie es wagen
[Applaus]
Seit mehr als 30 Jahren ist die
Wissenschaft kristallklar, wie können Sie es wagen,
weiterhin wegzuschauen und hierher zu kommen und zu sagen, dass
Sie genug tun, wenn die Politik
und die erforderlichen Lösungen immer noch nicht
in Sicht sind  Sie sagen, Sie hören uns und
Sie verstehen die Dringlichkeit, aber egal
wie traurig und wütend ich bin, ich will das nicht
glauben, denn wenn Sie
die Situation wirklich verstehen und
weiterhin nicht handeln würden, wären Sie böse,
und das lehne ich ab  zu  Glauben Sie, dass die populäre
Idee, unsere Emissionen in
10 Jahren zu halbieren, uns nur eine 50-prozentige Chance gibt,
unter 1,5 Grad zu bleiben, und das
Risiko irreversibler
Kettenreaktionen, die sich der menschlichen Kontrolle entziehen, 50 %
für Sie akzeptabel sein kann, aber diese Zahlen
beinhalten nicht  kipppunkte die meisten
rückkopplungsschleifen zusätzliche erwärmung versteckt
durch giftige luftverschmutzung oder die aspekte von
gerechtigkeit und klimagerechtigkeit sie
verlassen sich auch darauf, dass meine generation
hunderte milliarden tonnen ihres co2 aus
der luft saugt mit technologien die kaum
existieren also ein 50% risiko ist  einfach nicht
akzeptabel für uns, die wir
mit den Konsequenzen leben müssen, eine 67-
prozentige Chance zu haben, unter einem
globalen Temperaturanstieg von 1,5 Grad zu bleiben. Die
besten Chancen, die vom IPCC angegeben werden, die Welt
hatte am 1. Januar noch 420 Gigatonnen CO2 zu
emittieren  2018 heute ist diese
Zahl bereits auf weniger als 350 Gigatonnen gesunken.
Wie können Sie es wagen, so zu tun,
als könne dies mit dem üblichen Geschäft
und einigen technischen Lösungen
von heute verkauft werden?  s-emissionswerte, dass die
verbleibenden co2-budgets in weniger als achteinhalb jahren vollständig aufgebraucht sein werden, wird
es hier heute keine lösungen oder
pläne geben, die diesen
zahlen entsprechen, weil diese
zahlen zu unbequem sind und sie noch
nicht reif genug sind, sie zu sagen  Es sieht so aus, als würden
Sie uns im Stich lassen, aber die jungen
Leute fangen an, Ihren Verrat zu verstehen,
die Augen aller zukünftigen Generationen sind
auf Sie gerichtet, und wenn Sie sich entscheiden, uns zu enttäuschen,
sage ich, wir werden Ihnen niemals vergeben
[Applaus],
wir werden Sie nicht bekommen lassen  Weg damit,
hier und jetzt ziehen wir
die Grenze, die Welt wacht auf und
Veränderungen kommen, ob es Ihnen gefällt oder
nicht, danke
[Applaus]